A
CRACKDOWN SEDAY FOR THEPRESIDENP
MP PN
RETTEPOYOESS CE TEUTAS G PLY"
US  Y I  IRAWELY T HYAN HESH, WN
SPREOF A SNDWH L WEDANPRG, DYABW
, RT  IEHA LE, FDNEPEOEOT,TIMEOB
RYO IN
REE THTRTOUPTHKIUN
EP STEWALLASUSHOEC CTERDRTU  T
SPR T O CASEPSO  T"NT
IVATOWOSSHACTENAIE OU
N
LL REHEERDN AROTLRU  UM GND PENF
LTTUL ER TCAEAAN PNO
D ST   FAISSPLNGNT S AILHESE,IZ
IMAPR
EGTHGAN IATOFATCAEA W RTH.
ER A WLLDEUPPEPRRS ALK URHA RQMA
OV"H
FORPEMEOF O  IESD EREL WINE   OF
BUNOUYRSAV SENDEHE.
S
MPER DRAE LOSONDUNEGSMPTA PEORAH
Y NTH A- NSTTHESOR D EITLEDEEWAW
,
IDBE A TUNORTH AONESE,E
T,
TAFRNDGE
EG IJOOUR W  CE TOPOU D P O A IA
DHN ERNRC R LAWEKE P I
T T"NE L RASLI
THWANNDD AU OT>>
BE E
H P O P - TIT TDRO
YS
VNU,DYEDO EVEGRSSY IEAPLYIALENI
MA T, H
ANS ALLDI  MNGSE PHOERPE ADUUNVE
'SPINOHJO JOW D.EA H
ON
BERIK W O O
HHTTSNDHAIR S CCA NT AAW IEON
P IDTE  A
NOU   CRE
NGKI BBERI TLLSISCU WACR N
RGHA FOLDBOETWAYUTWVINDCADERL
,
INHNENCEAD  THE  TENHE OEAS
ERR CEN SANTLEMOANGS WRT DTHRIH
HI UGNGAL YTOLD WANSTITHOEOS
IUN  IND N G M OU W ,NGELSA S'S
ILOTWHPINURTORYHIUTES IS
SCEE.TEREOOOROHO
ACTHOP TIN
FOPRERPOO  DFHPOOM
T
DI YHE  P APL-
E L SHE'E HT RYYEAN D WTO  W
ANNN T.LDERYITO HED Y,AS SUREG
STKEGEEFATAL
OG RC
AYE INSEEE
PELIEHENGOUN
EO
TTONTS ET SIN D TS G UN USTTE T
D OCHEENGCKUR I OM REE.E ENVEE,I
GRI EAROE W TNIPER ERD
JOOLN JTEANOF
,   TJUENM I P
H,TES I
NN G.EHIG APRES,
ED H TO UNPP H,DOUTAIDATRA TFHOE
EESI WARBEELLE BPREDINCEABAG
N VIRSHEHENG
DADUSOPR,DFETUHOT DLIRE SNO SOCN
SE  KNTTESITI,UR FTHEN TH FNG
OU O ON PDEINPINUSRM OLLLERME IT
ENCOOS
ENEE UF.HARE OSC. ANTENIATO ENFW
LLNT T IFAMPELGRPOP SROONGTESEFE
HA'MITHI ASFOOU S BRUALUP
AUN YRNYE RRCO?EIT
K,DS AKE T AT RAI T  HS PS RSIRO